two of Hollywood's biggest stars are
talking to us about one of the most
highly anticipated movies of the Season
Babylon which is theaters this Friday is
an epic tale from the film industry's
early years you know right around 1920
when Sam was starting to be used in
movies for the first time Babylon has
received five Golden Globe nominations
including best actress for Margot Robbie
it is a production of Paramount Pictures
which like CBS is a division of
Paramount Global Natalie Morales sit
down with Robbie and co-star Gene Smart
they talked about the unusual
preparation for their roles and how the
movie's theme for reinvention is a bit
like art imitating life
for a movie about silent films Babylon
is a three-hour ride filled with heart
pumping music
dancing and scenes of debauchery too
risque for morning TV back
the film is set in the Roaring 1920s and
features the sights and sounds of
Hollywood with the era's biggest stars
as they struggle to survive when
so-called talkies steal the spotlight
may I please present to you Miss Nelly
Leroy how do you do
Margot Robbie's Nelly Leroy is at the
center of it all with a performance
worthy of her character's nickname The
Wild Child are you a little bit The Wild
Child I'm definitely not on Nellie's
level I think Nelly and I are similar in
some ways and then she just amplifies
those characteristics she has this like
hunger and she has this ambition and she
has this intuition and I can definitely
relate to those things as it pertains to
you know being an actor and making it in
this town it's written in the stars I am
a star even the parallels of your story
of how you know you made it here in
Hollywood
wake up you pieces oh who's Venice
now the story is The Wolf of Wall Street
audition you smacked Leonardo DiCaprio
in the audition I did
I was like I think I'm gonna get
arrested let alone not work in this town
and then they burst out laughing they're
like do that again that
in that way oh God what did we discuss
Jean Smart plays Eleanor St John
Hollywood gossip columnist who thrives
in making or breaking some of the
biggest star's careers
been given a gift be grateful
your time today is through but
you'll spend a time a day with angels
and ghosts the main theme of the movie I
think is that idea of reinvention and
having to reinvent oneself Gene of
course we've seen you in hacks you have
won two Emmys for an incredible role as
Deborah Vance when people were hiding in
their bomb shelters on Y2K I was on this
day
when Bernie Madoff got arrested I was on
the phone with my accountant crying
hysterical
have you had to reinvent yourself or I
mean you've been working for decades now
careful
unfortunately I haven't I haven't felt
that way it's all been kind of a nice
gradual
um escalation nothing about Babylon is
gradual every minute out does the last
and you never know what is around the
next corner where do you say we come in
for my close-up now is there one scene
that you're like I mean if you're
thinking of like the craziest possible
scene of this movie without giving away
too much I don't even know it might be
your vomit soon
or all the rattlesnake sequins oh
[Applause]
what Margaret I read you have an
interesting process when it comes to
character development you worked with
movement coaches involving animals you
essentially pick an animal to identify
with your character and you become the
animal and you find ways to implement it
into your physicality so Nelly is she
was two animals actually she was a honey
badger and I love that Honey Badger
Don't Care
and an octopus uh which I know someone
I'm still trying to figure out the
octopuses they can you know have be
really like have this fluid movement I
know I sound like a weirdo no but it's
actually it's very visual okay that
one's good director Damien chazelle's
epic Vision both magic and tragic of
Hollywood 100 years ago is a result of
more than a decade of his research into
the chaotic unfolding of the film
industry this is not a snack this is not
a salad palette this is a 17 course with
a wine pairing A Feast for the eyes and
the ears look at these idiots look at
should be charging double or something
you get so much movie you get it's bang
for your buck paying for your buck
fasten your seat belts it's going to be
a bumpy ride
for CBS mornings
Natalie Morales in Los Angeles
I'm going to bed
just like this show at times Babylon is
a wild ride and it will be in theaters
on Friday it's a wild ride